Oh YouTube just lovers in offense this
is grunge in here and today we are going
to learn how to defeat accelerated
dragon now in recent years
accelerated dragon become very very
popular and it's one of the very
interesting and dynamic Sissel in
defense position now the system I am
going to show you again secretary dragon
which is kind of odd and that's why it's
very hard for your opponent to come up
with exact models ok let's start so what
we'll start with the move evil and black
will reply with the c5 and here I am
recommending Knight to f3 and after
black respond with Knight to c6 here we
will play Knight to c3 now the normal
moves for that created dragon is g6 but
here comes a big shock for your point
because here we are not going to play d4
or going back to the main line of the
accelerated dragon but we will shock him
with smooth which is h4 and now you can
see the idea is very simple we want to
play h5 and embarrass the King side of
the back
let's see what happens if the x-rated
dragon player carries out his routine
moves so for example the routine moves
here for the exited dragon player is
Bishop to g7 after that we'll play h5
and if now Knight f6 then here comes the
blow which is at six
and now you can see that Bishop has no
square except he has to go back and once
the bishop goes to the f8 thought only
it unde L upper piece but it also create
a long time problem for the black and
that means black King will remain in the
center for a long time and look at a
pawn or at six it's a big monster
so that is completely out of the
question so black cannot play its normal
moves so that means here black has to
play this move which is Knight to f6 but
here the lightning strikes from the
different direction because now we are
going to shock him once again with this
move which is e Phi now at first sight
it looks like it's not possible for
white because after Knight to g4
attacking the ball
if white defends the pawn with the Queen
to e2
and black can response with the Bishop
to g7 and that means that Paul is a
goner
but however that's not why it's idea
the whites main area is when black plays
Knight to g4 white wants to play this
move which is H Phi and now
there are few reply over here for the
black let's take the first one which is
bird up this one black will take the
pawn why not if Knight G cross e file
then this will be the last time your
opponent is going to take the pawn
because we have a very very forcing
sequence right now which give a plus
position for white before we go home if
you pause the video and find out a
winning sequence for the whiter okay I
hope you find out the win sequence and
it runs like this so white will play
Knight cross night and when black
recapture the night fight will play f4
now you can see that Knight has only one
square so when the night goes back to c6
will play H cross g6 and now you can see
the edge pot is right now pin so black
has to forcefully capture with that pawn
so f cross g6 and now I hope you find
this move which is Bishop to d3 and how
the hell on earth
black will defend that threat the only
logical reply looks like Bishop to g7
but I wonder if you can spot amazing
more here
okay the amazing movies rook takes at
seven so it's a bomb barring on the
neighborhood and if the Rope takes rope
then we have this move Bishop takes g6
and not only white regain the piece but
black King will lost the castle rights
and also white will be upon up so this
will be a great game for the white so
that means Knight cross Aoife is not
possible for the black so that leads to
only sensible reply which is at this
point Black has to play Bishop to g7 and
ignoring the epon but against this why
it has a very cunning idea and that
start with a move Knight to g5 and now
you can see a White Queen is attacking
the Black Knight now here black has a
few options the first option if the
Black Knight retrieved to the passive
squares then white has a very good reply
with the who f4 and now you can see why
it has a very good center and not only
that white has a tremendous pressure on
the hatch file and that will give great
advantage to the white in second option
if Black Knight takes the pawn so for
example nigt phi then against this we
have a very amazing move which is H
across g6 and now if the F cross g6 or
the knight cross g6 then that leads to
the positional disaster for the black
that means white will have a great
attack on the edge file if the black
king castle shot so the most logical
reply after the edge cross g6 is to take
with H bone but here white will first
exchange the pair of the rook rook takes
rook and Bishop takes rook here white
will play f4 and now you can see that
night is strapped it does not have any
good spares so the only good reply left
for the black is to play f6 but after
this fight will simply play Knight to d4
and when the knight Black Knight goes to
the only square which is night to
epsilon I give you a few seconds can you
find amazing more here which can give a
great advantage to the white
okay the move is Queen to g4 and first
sight it looks like it's not possible
because here black can win a piece by
two different way let's look at them
each by turn for example our first move
by the black will be very obvious fi
attacking the two pieces but now white
can simply capture the g6 if you open
and foolishly take the knight then that
leads to checkmate so that's not
possible and another reply which is here
if you open or the black play defy
then again white can capture the pond
and after D cross e for Queen check and
the King goes to the d7 you can see not
only white can regain the knight but
black King can hardly describe as a safe
and to give you an illustration I can
show you one of my own game which can
give you an idea how dangerous this
position is for the black so in one of
my game
my opponent play Knight to be for now
attacking my C 2 square and not only
that it's it will folk the rook and the
King
but here I played a very cunning move
which is I invite him to take the rook
and I played Queen to c4 he just
captured my pawn and after I play King
to d1 he captured my rope and I give you
a few seconds can you identify a
sequence where you can get black Queen
over here
okay the move is first of all Queen to
defy check and now black has the two
options the King goes to the c7 then
this will nab the Queen immediately
so once the King moves then we can get
the Queen so that's the first option the
second option the value of this response
is King to e8 but after this we have a
very good move which is Bishop to b5
check and now you can see if black
foolishly play Bishop to d7 then that
leads to check late so that's not
possible and if the King runs away to f8
we get the black queen
so see how much dangerous these
positions are for second player okay
let's look at the last option where
here it is possible that black can play
move such sd-6 trying to protect the
night with the bishop but this is the
most dangerous scenario for the black
because I give you a couple of seconds
try to find a very amazing mower here
okay the move is a six so after a six it
will cut the communication of the knight
and the bishop that means our queen is
again attacking the knight and not only
that our two pcs are attacking they have
seven square and this is the disaster
position of the black so by playing this
kind of cunning Morris not only white
can trick the black in exited dragon but
in many lines as I have demonstrated
over here you can get a very good
positions and there are many traps exist
as well and I give you guarantee many of
your opponents will be fall into that I
hope now you will feel confident against
exited dragon this tough luck for trying
the system against your opponent and
feel free to comment on my video
I'll meet you soon bye